[Musique]
les travaux ont démarré puisque c'est
aujourd'hui certainement un des plus
gros sites de travaux pour la
préparation la préparation des sols tout
ce qui est la préparation avant la
construction et donc il ya énormément de
machines qui sont sur le site à poissy
pour créer les trois grandes plateformes
sur lequel nous viendrons construire le
centre de formation pour les jeunes et
le centre d'entraînement pour les
professionnels et donc les construction
des bâtiments eux-mêmes devraient
démarrer dans le courant de l'année 2021
pour s'achever au début de l'année 2000
on va rassembler sur un même site des
les équipes des plus jeunes dès dès le
plus jeune âge des les neuf ans
jusqu'aux professionnels on va
rassembler sur un même site l'ensemble
des professionnels et des jeunes qui va
nous permettre au club de de détecter de
et de portes et de développer les
talents
régionaux des yvelines mais au delà de
la région parisienne pour les faire
grandir
et puis leur leur donner un coup de
l'aspiration pour leur donner envie
d'aller s'entraîner aussi à terme sur
les terrains des pros il est important
comme dans tous les grands clubs
européens pour doter le paris
saint-germain d'infrastructures qui
permettent de de s'entraîner dans
l'excellence de faire progresser les
jeunes de créer cette mécanique
aspirationnel et donc à terme d'avoir
dans l'équipe de plus en plus de jeunes
qu'ils sont innés qui seront in et de la
formation du paris saint germain